buonasera a tutti si sono lorenzo giorgi
e sono un quadrante internazionale se mi
chiedete quando ho iniziato a fare il
corrente internazionale non ve lo so
dire
tutti voi avete una data in cui iniziare
il vostro un tratto io non lo so forse
ho iniziato a fare il corrente
internazionale quando ho cominciato ad
amare lo sviluppo
quando lasciando ingegneria ho
cominciato a girare in tanzania amici
sono un attimo penso questo tornare in
tanzania con italia poi in kenya e mi
sono veramente un po perso in alcuni
progetti e li ho cominciato a vedere
come lo sviluppo ci invadesse invadesse
me che lavorava in tanzania essere
villaggi masài avesse le grosse comunità
e le grosse metropoli africane e
accorgevo come ogni piccolo ogni piccola
diversità ogni piccola novità in un
contesto mi sembrava sviluppo e mi
chiedevo quanto è sostenibile volte
questo sviluppo quanto crea
diseguaglianza questo sviluppo che la
cooperazione internazionale sta portando
e allora lì ho cominciato appassionarmi
di tutto quello era il cambiamento e ho
cominciato a dire se noi noi la mia
generazione o 26 anni sono il più
piccolo dall'azione in questo speaker e
se la mia generazione vuol portare
sviluppo dove che deve cambiare rispetto
all'assistenzialismo è stato fatto fino
adesso è mancato qualcosa in questo
sviluppo e avevo paura che anch'io come
abituale di sentirmi complice di di un
sistema che ormai portato assoluta
assistenzialismo
mi sono accorto insieme a tanti altri
che mancava qualcosa mancava forse
l'accettazione del limite ma dovevamo
capire qual era il limite in cui
dobbiamo fermarci pensare e ripartire
per me il limite e sarà una cosa
fondamentale cioè noi siamo entrati nel
ventesimo secolo prima con i
totalitarismi poi con il trionfo delle
tecnoscienze e pensavamo che li
limitatezza fosse la soluzione pensavamo
che tutto potesse essere fattibile e
invece questo lavorare sotto gli ultimi
cinquant'anni di limiti ed insostenibili
anni ha portato avanti
chiaramente la cooperazione
internazionale negli ultimi anni ha
portato vero il proprio assistenzialismo
e allora abbiamo detto cosa fare
pensiamo a quello che è stato fatto di
male negli ultimi anni perché non
potevamo più prendere solo gli aspetti
positivi del dello sviluppo io faccio
questo progetto perché porta sviluppo e
questi sono i benefici e non guardavamo
mai chi rimaneva indietro allora io che
sono un po folle e mi piace studiare
tutti i filosofi che ruotano contro
quello io faccio ovvero che criticano la
globalizzazione criticano lo sviluppo
allora ho preso il mio amato s'erge la
fruscio ha cominciato a studiare lo
studio del limite e mi sono accorto come
la touche elencava tutti questi limiti
che voi vedete da quelli morali fino
arrivare a quelli economici
chiaramente la touche parlava in un
contesto sia demografico che finanziario
perciò non doveva creare una conseguenza
di questi limiti e e ci siamo detti che
prendessimo questa analisi che parla
male dello sviluppo e parla male della
cooperazione internazionale parla male
della finanza e per le mani della
validazione e la trasformassimo allora
in questo schema non c'è più il limite
di cultura il limite culturale per un
cooperante internazionale non avrebbe
senso sarebbe troppo miope usare la
cultura come un limite alla cultura in
questo caso diventa la culla da cui
riparte tutto la colla da cui noi
partiamo creare vere e proprie
progettazioni e vedete che il limite di
conoscenza per noi cooperanti
internazionali diventa o deve diventare
o dovrebbe diventare lo start la cosa
fondamentale perché se la tuscia
considerava e analizzava nel suo
pessimismo i limiti noi dovevamo capire
come dare gli strumenti in mano alle
persone nei paesi in via di sviluppo
dovevamo smettere di donare pacchi
alimentari
dovevamo smettere di finanziare progetti
non sostenibili e dovevamo attraverso il
limite di conoscenza dare gli strumenti
alle persone penalizzata per danneggiare
i limiti morali per analizzare quelli
geografici e territoriali per capire
come un social business e conosce i
limiti
economici del loro organismo e della
loro società allora questo è quello che
noi dobbiamo creare dobbiamo creare
sostenibilità
niente di più la commercio
internazionale non deve far altro che
creare sostenibilità allora quando
comincio a pensare a quelli che sono
state ea volte discusso con i miei
colleghi e dico
sapete quanto è stato speso negli ultimi
50 anni o quanti fondi sono stati emessi
a livello ministeriale statale da tutti
i paesi del mondo del nord per tutti i
paesi del mondo del sud sono stati spesi
2.300 miliardi di dollari potevano wow è
tanto non siete riusciti a creare niente
no siamo riusciti a creare
assistenzialismo allora tutti cominci a
dire allora tale se non riuscite a fare
altro leviamogli anche voi se di fondi
lo fermi fermi fermi gli ultimi 50 anni
tutti i paesi del mondo hanno spesso
2.300 miliardi di dollari per far perché
all assistenzialismo ma solo gli stati
uniti d'america in 50 anni hanno speso
17 miliardi dollari per per le loro
spese militari
allora forse correnti meno ridotte le
spese per la cooperazione internazionale
chiaramente ci fu un articolo di sterli
qualche anno fa dove lui disse un po
provocazione un po perché serviva
repubblicani americani di se questi
2.300 dall 2.300 miliardi di dollari
esclude anche per me sono numeri un
attimino folli non sono servite a niente
non forse no sono no non è vero che non
sono servite a niente
e chiaro che hanno prodotto poco hanno
prodotto male questo do ragione a
easterly sono stati spesi tanti soldi
male e allora finché non riusciremo a
creare sostenibilità di conseguenza non
arriverà automaticamente lo sviluppo è
un circolo virtuoso che semplice
sentiamo strumenti alle popolazioni via
di sviluppo per creare cambiamento
se noi chiediamo conoscenza ma
ovviamente nasce la sostenibilità perché
le popolazioni hanno gli strumenti
adatti per costruirsi il futuro
e allora arriviamo allo sviluppo
un giorno andai in facoltà da un mio
professore studiavo cooperazione
internazionale e dissi professore ho
trovato un circolo virtuoso e se ne è
figo pesci problema conoscenza sostiene
lo sviluppo è fatta perché tutti non ne
parla il ministro oggi non ti eccita
reintegrati con fermati un attimo è
chiaro come chiaro ma è chiaro nei libri
ma perché io quando vado in giro o con
tanti miei colleghi non lo vediamo
questo perché ci perdiamo la
sostenibilità all'interno dei progetti
dov'è che quell anello mancante dove
sfugge litigammo vediamo chiaramente vi
posso giurare la settima dopo avevo un
esame con lui non andava tanto bene però
questo è un'altra cosa
questo circolo virtuoso è fondamentale
perché porta a dargli gli strumenti alle
persone questo il limite di conoscenza e
quello che su cui ho deciso di lavorare
io come tanti altri colleghi cioè la
ridefinizione del concetto di formazione
professionale non scolastica esposto
scolastica scusate mi sembra un azzardo
sembra assurdo ma è fondamentale perché
non ha senso spingere soltanto
sull'educazione stradale statale e
decidere paese occidentale dove un paese
del sud del mondo deve investire o dopo
o in che modo un paese al sud del mondo
deve investire nella sua prova
educazione scolastica signore ma se non
gli diamo gli strumenti ci arriveranno
da soli a quale sarà il meglio per loro
se noi destiniamo bene i fondi
loro decideranno come crearsi la
sostenibilità esistono paesi del sud del
mondo e si sono poi sviluppati ma non
penso che siano contenti di rimanere
quel modo e allora noi dobbiamo cercare
di capire che non ha più senso spingere
perché le migliaia di laureati in una
nazione in ruanda uganda in sudafrica in
africa qualunque contesto non ha senso
creare migliaia di laureati in un paese
che non ha gli strumenti per sfruttare
quelle competenze
però dobbiamo far sì che la nostra
progettazione abbia insita dentro esiste
una sostenuta che serve a creare
formazione questo è fondamentale
e tutto questo va fatto nel rispetto
dell unico concetto fondamentale che
forse sta prima forse a volte
conseguente alla sostenibilità e allo
sviluppo e rispetto per le popolazioni
perché noi dobbiamo aver rispetto per
qualunque bambino che nascerà in quella
comunità dove noi lavoriamo e per
qualunque anziano che fino a quel
momento ha fatto il meglio di sé e ha
lavorato al meglio per portare avanti la
sua comunità questo è un aspetto
fondamentale che a volte nella
cooperazione internazionale soprattutto
a livelli alti perdiamo mai ha deciso di
lavorare per progetti dove il rispetto
per le comunità viene avanti alla
protezione e alla creazione del progetto
dello sviluppo sé per sé creare sviluppo
e sostenuta nell'emergenza è l'aspetto
successivo perché se nelle progettazioni
nternazionali classiche noi creiamo
sviluppo e sostenibilità è semplice ma
oggigiorno di accorgersi di quanti
cataclismi guerre inondazioni eventi
naturali eventi climatici e la noi siamo
costretti a lavorare in situazioni di
emergenza
tempi stretti rischio massimo
percentuale d'errore alto non dovete mai
sbagliare perché se sbagliate ci mette
la popolazione è giusto
e allora dobbiamo esser bravi a far sì
che il nostro intervento in quei momenti
durante le emergenze noi fa di crisi se
un intervento non sprecato a breve
termine ma si è integrato a lungo
termine e non credete a chi dice che è
impossibile creare a lungo termine
sostenuta durante l'emergenza perché in
tanti progetti ci sono riusciti in tanti
lavora in emergenza vuol dire sistemare
occupare da ribery primari ma in questo
è inutile continuare a dare pacche è
inutile continuare a tenere aperti i
centri rifugiati in giro per il mondo
grossi come la città dove vivo sono la
fa proprio a prato siamo 200 mila
abitanti
ho lavorato in etiopia e nono centro
rifugiati di 190 mila abitanti
mi sembrava come stare a casa
praticamente e vi farò vedere un video
adesso dove si vede come in una
situazione di emergenza si riesce a
creare intervento d'emergenza sviluppo
sostenibilità e creazione del social
business
tutto questo in isola delle filippine
non muovendo 112.000 cooperanti ma
lavorando insieme alla comunità
così la nella filanda nei consensi su
noi stessi li sai baba non guido
consente lega ai masters di aborto
movente né troyes si lamenta ben stiller
in un momentino costruiamo una frusta
lega spara elettrica ion boom per la
sillaba yara
qui re energy studies ha tentato di
symbolic è qui che 2t inaugurata a
weekend due to any of thailand in town
energy povere dio quella tra le gambe
se se vi state chiedendo chi è stato a
costruire quel illuminazione e allungare
quell'isola ea creare un social business
per illuminare l'inps le isole limitrofe
risponde alla comunità di lo ilo sono
passati quattro tecnici è un tot di
ingegneri per andare a insegnare a cui
la popolazione come autocostruirsi
d'illuminazione sfruttando l'energia
solare e non sono diventato il primo
esempio di social business nelle
filippine su energia solare e loro hanno
illuminato le altre isole che aveva
perso elettricità in seguito al tifone
ora chiuderò con l'altra slide questo
forse apparentemente non c'entra niente
con cui ho parlato fino adesso questa
che il kossovo il 1998 e avevo 10 anni è
stata la prima guerra che io mi sono
vissuto in televisione se questa
immagine qua avessi messo un immagine di
adesso della siria o dei profughi
siriani non sarebbe cambiato niente
il problema è che sono passati tanti
anni sono passati tanti anni sono
passati 16 anni e siamo ancora a questi
livelli
io chiedevo ai miei genitori perché
quelle persone avevo 9 anni dieci anni
perché quelle persone stanno camminando
dove vanno lì che scappano non hanno
niente non lo zaino e lui mi guarda mi
dicevano riguardarlo perché quella della
verità a dare la vita e io da qui non ho
più chiuso gli occhi e ho cominciato
forse qui entrata un po la passione per
lavorare nei paesi in via di sviluppo
questo è una situazione insostenibile e
tuttora è situata in tutto il mondo e
non esiste un mondo b non esiste un
piano b sia dal punto di vista ecologico
ma dal punto di vista della popolazione
questo mondo diventa insostenibile se la
mia generazione
i miei colleghi e chi lavora nella
cooperazione internazionale continua ad
e nutrire la mente delle popolazioni
grazie mille